Janet Musyoka has just buried her 14
year old daughter Harriet Donga was in a
school building that collapsed last
month in Nairobi killing eight children
me Manila Kufa name we live in by I died
with her that day there's no life
without her she tells us Harriet had
just been transferred to the school and
was preparing for her final primary
school exams mia tasuku Virginia I did
not think it was that serious when I got
the information when I reached the gates
I did see the school building it was
flattened I went straight to air class
it was in just so blood
it was so confused since then the Kenyan
government has ordered the shutdown of
about 300 community and private schools
mainly in low-income areas thousands of
children will be affected so this is ep1
and ep2 several schools in Nairobi have
already been closed like st. Catherine
primary who country will step on the
floor which was once used as a bar
selling traditional alcohol the owner
tells us he sent all 200 children home
when government inspectors say the
building is not safe and also we
considered that up we should not use way
too material that is why we used light
material so that but they said that the
floor was dancing then I was millions of
children attend community or private
schools in poor neighborhoods because
they're cheaper public schools are free
but they are too few crowded and far
apart this school has just over a
hundred pupils some when classrooms on
the first floor but government officials
have said all children should be on the
ground floor until inspectors come by to
approve the structure teachers say the
school is mostly run by money from
nonprofit organizations and some payment
of school fees by poor parents they also
accuse some government officials of
corruption for allowing substandard
schools to operate of course it is the
government because if we have us who
like this one yeah they always come to
our school to do their
they check what is going on in different
schools when the structures are okay
there the attorneys are there whether
the health is we are we are observing
all these rules and and when they come
and live where do they live the
structures standing if they are
substandard Jane mousakas pain is far
from over
she says she trusted teachers and the
government with her daughter's life now
she wants justice Catherine saw a al
Jazeera Nairobi